who is protecting the athletes there's
no teams there's no union there's
there's no i mean there's five or six
different organizations i think back
to
there's something that happened in the
the last tyson fury deante wilder fight
that hit me
so hard to my core he fired his
training his training staff deonte
wilder wow because they his his coroner
stopped the fight he was cut and diante
wilder fired him because he was like you
need to let me die in the ring i never
quit i'm not a quitter and his corner
stopped the fight deante wilder
seriously said you got to let me die and
i go out on my on my shield and that hit
me so hard because i feel the i felt the
exact same way if when i was in the
minor leagues adam i [ __ ] you not if you
told me gerard here's a pill and if you
take this pill you're going to the major
leagues but you're going to die at 40. i
would have taken it without even
thinking twice i would have gobbled it
before you could have even described any
the anything outside of my immediate
goal was so abstract than anything i
wanted bro you're locked out i would
have traded anything i would have traded
second half of my life to achieve that
goal you're locked in dude who is
protecting you guys from yourselves the
trainers
they're supposed to
the wives the girlfriends back in 2009 i
was getting ready for the mr olympia on
that thursday night i wasn't feeling
right next you know i'm puking my brains
out i lost 20 pounds within that time
period emts were called at 5 30 in the
morning
and they did not want me to compete
and i probably shouldn't have
but
yeah was i praying to god saying like
please let me compete absolutely
because i'm thinking my purpose was like
these fans have flown so far that i just
need to show up i just want to show up i
just want to do it i just want to try
i'm not going to win but i want to try
and i made it and i had to make a deal
with the emts and say like if i get sick
one more time while they're there i have
to quit and i didn't but they still
stayed for like another hour
to check vitals and this and that um
you know i almost feel bad for even you
know and i'm not comparing myself but
it's going back to what you're saying i
mean my mindset was just like i got to
keep going
so it is hard
but again i wasn't by myself when i was
sick
so you have to make sure if any advice
for the athletes you got to make sure
guys that you are not by yourself maybe
maybe maybe maybe let me ask you a
different question maybe uh
is how often does the mr olympia brand
hold trainers accountable and have
conversations with them what's the
relationship between the brand and the
trainers if they're that heavily
involved in these types of decisions
good question in addition to that what
what's the qualifications to be an
olympia trainer how do you do these guys
are they olympia certified how do you i
mean it'd be no different than a boxing
trainer it's the same thing so i mean
like
it's the same thing like but i'm curious
the first one is there a relationship
between mr olympia and the trainers or
no okay i mean it's not like so it's
independent they can do whatever they
want to do right okay and ultimately i'm
just going to call for what it is i mean
we're grown men
women whatever that compete
i have to be okay with what i do with my
own body as well but what gerard was
saying earlier who's protecting the
athlete from themselves
and usually it's supposed to be your
team and i have always
made sure that i did have my best friend
there my girl there my trainer there
some some like when i say my best friend
like he would be the one that if
something were to happen he'd be he'd
look me in the eye and say i've known
you for the longest out of anybody i
think you need to stop
and i would and he would be the one that
i would listen to so i think athletes
moving forward
you always got to make sure
that you have someone that
will
hit that button for you and you respect
it
because you just don't want to push
yourself too far
in anything
i mean pat
you you have a best friend
that would probably sit you down and be
like hey man you know you're working too
much this and that you know or hey man i
i think you need to spend more time with
your family or whatever and you would
listen to him i think we all had those
people told me you had panic attacks
anxiety attacks plenty of them yeah yeah
and
you know it just
yeah this this is a different world
because this is i didn't put stuff you
know i'm not yeah no it's a very
different world in you're dealing with
chemical and you're definitely i mean
i'm just going to call it for what it is
you're you're definitely dealing with
uh you know chemical muscle enhancement
you're definitely dealing with certain
things i'm not going to speculate on
what he was doing or anything like that
all i know is that my friend died man
he passed and and you know um i'm
i don't i i just need more information i
need more data so listen i just wanted i
just i thought it was i appreciate you
know you sharing because i'm sure the
audience is is uh wondering what your
thoughts are and i saw where you were at
before i thought it was appropriate for
you to share your thoughts with it and
uh to the bodybuilding world man you
know it's a
it's one of those things that when a guy
decides to go compete in that world it's
tough to explain the hide the desire to
want to do that it's not for everybody
people think it's just a regular thing
it's so technical and detailed for what
they do um
uh prayers goes out to george and his
family on what they're going through
right now because at the end of the day
i wonder what they're thinking about
they're the ones that are probably going
through the toughest pains right now
seeing these stories coming from all
over the place so if if dylan ortiko
wanted to be a bodybuilder what would
you say
uh
like at what level
they want to be mr olympia i would say
only do it if you have a chance to win
the whole thing not to just compete
it's what i would say yeah only do it if
you have the chance i would have them
go sit with guys like him to say
you'd be a top 10 guy you ain't going to
be you're going to be so i don't think
you ought to do it and then at that
point if you want to do it you know for
yourself to have fun with that maybe
there's a couple of different companies
what you just said yeah i don't see a
point to do mr olympia unless if you're
gonna win the whole thing matter of fact
i don't even think there's point to
a lot of things until you can become
very very uh good at that world uh
everyone's got their own talent i think
there's uh certain people that like i
lived to this morning i was at the gym
early i loved right now what's going on
you right now training are you and i
gonna go compete senior mr olympia
anytime soon i don't know he may but he
was talking about the last time but but
the extreme nature of it doesn't doesn't
scare you i i think one of my kids is
going to pursue some kind of extreme
level of competition whether it's
business hollywood script sports you
know i don't know and there's nothing i
can tell them to stop because you
couldn't tell me anything to stop nobody
can tell me to stop you can't
there's you just can't tell somebody
like that what they're going to be doing
but
you said was really actually what you
said is actually what i told myself
was like if if i'm going to do this
i better make sure that i'm making a
living from it
and that i can get everything out of it
that i want
and if i'm doing the mr olympia best day
i'm sure be better be able to become
highly i mean highly competitive
and if i'm not i got to give myself like
three to five years and i got to pick
another path i agree yeah i agree you
said something that i just got i have
that question like to me you said you
would have done whatever drugs or
whatever it took
and if you were to be dead by the age of
40 so be it die on your sword in the
ring for sure that to me is is
look respect to your opinion that to me
is the exact opposite of how i'm living
my life
i want to live a long time i want to
have kids i want to have grandkids
that might have been like where you were
at when you were younger i can't explain
it to you right i'm not judging you i'm
just letting you know where i'm at i i i
feel a little judgment though i feel
like you are judging me
i just i think you see all these
athletes
you know the saddest thing i go to the
[ __ ] dolphins game and you see these
guys
and they get paraded out on the field
and they're 75 years old now and their
legacy is that they were the undefeated
team on the dolphins
50 years later they're like i was on the
team it's like buddy
do something else with your life at this
point i'm not saying that none of them
aren't dude you want to see one of the
best things in the world watch watch the
86 mets documentary that that's great we
talked about it a little bit uh once
upon a time in colleen's watch lenny
dykstra in that in that dock and then
they asked him they're like was it worth
it he goes i was on the greatest team in
the history of sports what else is ever
going to compare to that okay
the guy is toothless and brainless at
this point but that's my point is that
you're willing to sacrifice everything
for the first 25 30 years of your life
by the way the rest of your life
by the way the world is ran by those
people that's what i was gonna say yeah
yeah yeah yeah what do you mean let me
let me do it
you're right now the world is being run
by 70 and 80 years what country are you
living in right now the united states of
america okay the people who founded it
what did they do
they fought for their freedom of course
you think there were some people in
britain and they're like
don't ju don't compare lenny dykstra to
george washington or gerard no no wait
no no wait a minute
you said dolphins i'm not talking gerard
you said dolphins okay it's a very i'm
just saying it's people that give
everything dude you know what you just
said right there what did i say
are you talking about adam do you like
adam i think let me explain to you what
so you mean to tell me so right now your
22 year old son is watching this
and he's obsessed about being the
greatest whatever whatever whatever
you're going to tell them dude relax if
it means if that means if it means
putting some harmful products in nobody
i'm
i'm giving
using gerard's words if it means ruining
your body and literally gerard's a
little extreme and the way that that's
that's what i was saying no but you said
dolphins that's the type of compulsion
if you eliminate dolphins
i'm saying is it
for me is do you want to
die by 40
or
live a long
life i understand what you're saying
in a weird way i'll tell you in a weird
way
my body would have died but my legacy
would have lived on i would have been a
big leaguer forever
do you understand do you understand what
i'm saying like all my every doesn't do
anything for you nothing
what if you're a big leaguer but you
were on the bench the entire time you're
in the big leagues bro like i i don't
guys i don't i know it's dumb
i i don't know how to explain it to you
it's so funny i don't know how to
explain there's there's something
there's some minor leaguer out there
listening to this that knows exactly
what i'm saying okay
let me give you a little optics
you said if you were on the bench at
least you would have died on the bench
there's a big and i want you to live to
the literally you're 150 years old
he's
gonna go down a seven time mister that's
a legacy
you because you made it to the major
leagues and you you know you hit
220 for half a season that's something
that he has to do okay i get it but if
you ever use that i get it that's what
there's no values but is it
but to use pat's point if you're gonna
do this i want you to be the best of the
best the best not riding the pine no man
like that's what he said if dylan if
dylan ortik are going to do it he wants
him to be the old man champion the old
man and the sea yeah you ever read the
whole you're going to throw some ernest
hemingway
earnest what have you ever read it the
old man yes in eighth grade i had to
read it well
he was willing to die for that fish he
was [ __ ] willing to die for a fish
for that fish yeah i read moby dick for
that fish all right hey let me ask you a
question step outside with you right now
gerard hey you like dive in that fish
you like art right you like art pat
right he's the art guy okay so basquiat
how old did he die 27 right 27.
talk about impact is that a heroin
overdose so obviously he was doing it
like you know creating these uh
masterpieces right you know how
expensive those pieces are right now
we
very very expensive right pat a boss
yeah it's it's it's ridiculous yeah all
right let me give you let me let me
throw something in your way
would you rather would you rather be by
the way would you rather be
tupac
died by at age 25 or whatever would you
rather 25 is tupac dead and i'm not
joking about that like i'm not saying
that he's not like like he's not we've
covered one story yeah
he's gonna put this aside tupac's gonna
live forever these guys support us
in the morning
focus in the morning would you rather be
tupac or biggie they both died you know
in their 20s yeah or would you rather be
jay-z worth a billion and he's going to
live for until he's 100 years old well
who would you rather be you don't have a
choice though
you don't have to no you do not have a
choice i want to be jay-z no what i'm
trying to tell you is i love girls girls
yeah so so so the point i'm trying to
make to you is everyone's dreams are
different buddy get it but if you're
trying to solve your dreams end up dead
right now i guarantee you there's a
group of people listening to this that
fully subscribe to your way of thinking
fully
yeah and yeah this is a safe life i
fully get it and i guarantee there's a
group of by the way like your opinion
man
but the point is there's certain people
man who feel they got a calling on them
who feel like they want to do something
bigger and that life is not necessarily
the most exciting life to get to the
point of it becoming a reality that
journey can be annoying at times i i
feel you i get it but it's also i i'll
i'll use this analogy that i use with uh
when i do sauce talks
one minute we're changing the story
i see kids in their 20s that are
partying like there's no tomorrow in
south speech they're spending all their
money they're yoloing it up they're
killing it they're doing it and and i
have to remind them dude one day you're
going to be 30. one day you're going to
be at 40. dude don't spend all your
money
don't do all the drugs now
don't do all the drugs now you would
later do it
spread it out save your money
occasionally all right next have some
moderation dude like i'm done doing all
the drugs
you guys
did you guys go to the bar before this
with adam like is has adam had a few
drinks today
he's all over the place here he's all
over the place
i don't know what [ __ ] is going on i had
one goal zero value today
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you